good afternoon and
thanks for coming out to metro air
support today we're glad to have all of
you
we're going to go over three basic
topics today we're going to talk to
what we respond to out at air support
search and rescue
we're going to go over some 2020
statistics and then we're going to
talk about our top five to stay alive
search and rescue campaign
that we've been really hard on the last
two years we're committed to it it's on
our banner
above our door that all the pilots and
search and rescue officers
go in and out of every day and those are
just some
tips that will help you be more
successful in the
in the wild when you go recreate so
the first thing we do the most primary
thing we do is patrol support
so basically our helicopters this md530f
is used just like a
patrol car but it's in the sky flying
around the valley at 500 feet
a lot of times that's the helicopter you
hear it looks like it's flying low it's
always flying between four and six
hundred feet
we do search and rescue missions
obviously we do the
the rescues that are beyond the
capabilities of other agencies
so fire department responds to a lot of
them out at red rock
blm will respond national park service
respond
for the ones that we can allow them to
do
they're usually less than one mile that
the fire department or blm is going
and we're doing the more complex rescues
that require helicopter back in the
canyons
we respond to mass casualty and critical
incidents they
may require a tactical team be deployed
crime scene documentation we do that
with our cis
that has minimized a little bit since
we've implemented uh the drone
program out of our technical analytical
section they've taken over some of the
more
static things we do we still handle all
of the pursuits
and the critical dynamics stuff and the
drone
basically is used for crime scene
documentation right now
mountaintop radio repeater site
maintenance
a lot of people don't know and a lot of
other agencies don't know
we are the helicopters that maintain
those repeater sites and keep our radios
functioning
we take gas water and maintenance
personnel up to those mountain top
repeater sites
the next thing we'll talk about is some
of our 2020 statistics
so last year we flew 4316
incident-free flight hours with 84
percent
or 3 597 hours being in direct
patrol support responding to police
calls
crimes happening in the valley or
proactive
enforcement we did 110
search and rescue responses we recovered
eight dead bodies
that can be in the lake we do all of the
dive operations
for the national park service they will
locate a body
with their side scan sonar boats
and we are the ones that do the dive our
public safety divers
from las vegas metro do those body
recoveries
we do them on land as well in complex
areas if people fall off a cliff and die
and they're not found for some time
we also do those body recoveries with
the helicopters
we had 236 tactical medical responses
for our swat team
and other valley-wide swat teams where
our tactical
medics respond as the medical team
to handle any injuries or wounds that
come up during those swat call outs
our patrol helicopter crews made 2498
suspect observation and crime
observations
contributing to 994 arrests
via the helicopter
um last year in 2020 we averaged 22
calls per day in the helicopter
so it's quite a bit of work we're doing
up there
now on to our top five to stay alive
life-saving tips
for in the wild the most important thing
seems pretty simple and that is
simply telling somebody where you intend
to go hike or climb
and we recommend not going alone take
somebody with you
some of the rescues we have people are
out there alone they didn't tell anybody
where they go
somebody finds a car and we have to do a
massive
search in addition to the rescue we
later have to perform
checking the weather forecast is really
important for the area you intend
to hike or climb if you know it's going
to be windy
raining snowing you need to take that
into consideration for how you prepare
and what your skill level is
the third thing is to make sure to take
food water and a first aid kit
you know sometimes just a small backpack
with food a couple bottles of water some
granola bars
and a real brief tape first aid kit
that will suffice it will get you
through the night
take the appropriate gear in minimal
overnight provisions
always plan when you go out hiking that
something bad may happen
and you may have to spend the night
because you might not meet our criteria
for responding on a night helicopter
rescue
and the last thing is is to have a light
source
a charged phone and to consider a
personal locator beacon
if you're doing very remote or very
complex hikes or climbs
where the area is not well known to
a lot of people might be known to my
team but it might not be known to the
average person
so nobody else will be able to come get
you
personal locator beacons can be bought
at like bass pro shops or something like
that
uh basically any electronics store will
have them it's a good tool to have if
you do really extreme stuff
so with that that's our our basic
presentation
does anybody have any questions
can you guys go out to rescues when
people are you know hiking camping all
these things what are some of the more
common
things that lead to the rescues and how
can people try to prevent
we basically go off of three things
right people are either lost
stuck or hurt so they get lost we go on
a search for them we try to get them
back on trail
sometimes we have to recover them in the
helicopter sometimes we can send a
ground team on one of the atvs
and we can get them back without having
to deploy a helicopter
stuck is what we refer to technically as
being ledged out you climb up somewhere
which it's most often more often than
not it's easier to go up than it is to
come down so people will climb up
a rock structure and won't be able to
get down so they'll be ledged out
they will call us 9-1-1 and say i'm up
here but i can't get down
we evaluate those rescues on how
the where the area they're stuck in how
dangerous that is to them if they're on
a two foot ledge
whether it's day or night we're probably
going to come get you right away
if you're on a 10 foot you know base and
it's real nice and flat and you can
put your tent up that you took your
overnight provisions and you can wait
till the morning
we will defer that since you're not
injured we will defer that to a daytime
helicopter rescue so it's more safe for
our pilots
and then injuries you know we get ankle
injuries we get people fall
their cleats come out of the mountain
and they fall 40 feet and they
crack their skull so we run the whole
gamut from
fatality to no injury someone just being
stuck
ledged out and then all of the ankles
arms
broken legs we do it all
the time
it's actually not it's down right now
probably due to covid
uh the parks were closed for a while
like about eight months
the parks were closed completely so
people weren't allowed to go out there
legally some people still went out there
but
we've not seen a large increase
now we're actually seeing a big
reduction from last year so far we're
only at 27
so far this year but we have implemented
like i said in the last two years we've
implemented a lot of proactive sar
where those cards i have being handed
out to you when we're done
we hand those out we go to the parking
lots we have two search and rescue
officers right now out hiking
in red rock calico basin and they're
handing out those cards to people
to make sure everyone knows the basic
things that can help you
be successful when you go out to have a
good time in the park
anything else what other things do you
use to prepare for this season do you
increase the amount of fuel you have you
increase the number of bandages do
well you have to remember we're
responsible for rescue so we're always
ready
all of my men assigned in the search and
rescue section are in extremely
top level fitness top level because
like i said when i was speaking earlier
we have to do the rescues
that nobody else can do because we're
the only
helicopter rescue company in town nobody
else has a rescue helicopter
the medevac helicopters are merely for
transport
from the scene to the hospital they're
not to go into the wild the canyons
back in and they don't even have a hoist
on them like you see this hoist is
on the h-145 helicopter the baskets
there
they don't have that so we're we're
always ready
24 7 365 we're ready
and when no one else can get you las
vegas metro police has to get you that's
our job we're required the sheriff
is responsible for that and thankfully
sheriff lombardo knows the importance of
the unit
and he was a prior section commander he
used to be in my position
and he really understands the importance
of this unit
compare this summer to two summers ago
what has coca changed about your
responsibilities
just protocol in the helicopter we do
have dispatch ask the questions if you
call
we will ask you if you have the symptoms
we do mask our victims up
when our rescue team is down on the
ground packaging them
we do require them to mask up just minor
protocol stuff
with that
no we haven't seen that that was uh her
question we have not seen an
increase in rescues this year we're
right on about schedule and this is
typically
when we're coming into our busy season
spring and summer so that's why we're
here today to give those
those tips out so hopefully we can get
fewer rescues
because our rescue team we're just
response based right we're not out
there's
a little bit we could do to prevent some
of them by educating the public
but there's not a lot we can do to
prevent you from calling if you're out
on the rock
and you get lost stuck or hurt or you're
worried or you're scared
it's getting dark on you you don't have
a light when you call 9-1-1
we assess that me personally i assess
that and i decide how we're going to
respond
when we're going to respond and who's
going to be in the helicopter when we do
at any respond they call 9-1-1 there's
not a specific number for you guys
there's not we we want them to go
through 9-1-1 because obviously you know
metro
is the hub for all 9-1-1 our dispatchers
know our protocols so they can screen
some of those calls and we might be able
to send fire department first
fire department gets out there if they
can handle it it's less than a mile
it's not in any technical terrain and
they don't need us
if blm and fire department can handle it
we're okay
with that when it gets beyond their
capabilities that's when we get the call
and then our dispatchers will notify us
all right everybody